con estos datos argentinas supera con
creces la medida inflacionaria de la
región como ha llegado al país el país a
esta situación y qué lo diferencia del
resto
bueno Lamentablemente tenemos que estar
hablando de un cúmulo de políticas
equivocadas en especial un déficit
fiscal que se sigue monetizando un
déficit fiscal que debería ir en baja en
términos del pbi pero de ninguna manera
en términos nominales la inflación
esperada por el gobierno del 95% se
queda corta frente a la expectativa
privada del 100% y de las mejores
consultoras del 101,5% para este año la
inflación para los próximos 12 veces
será del 94% incide muchísimo en este
último dato de inflación para que no
haya sido superior el la postergación
del aumento de un rebalanceo tarifario
que va a repercutir en los meses
próximos Así que la situación es
delicada y no hay
una solución a la vista más que atarse a
lo firmado con el fmi en materia de
gastos en materia de déficit fiscal y
sobre todo de la no remisión de
utilidades del Banco Central al tesoro
para cubrir gastos corrientes y en el
día a día de los ciudadanos argentinos
cómo está afectando esta inflación Bueno
hay una encuesta
que habla de un 10% de caída en el
consumo sí de las tiendas o almacenes
los argentinos están remodelando sus
consumos para intentar ahorrar más y
obviamente que el incremento de precio
golpea El poder adquisitivo del bolsillo
de los trabajadores por quinto año
consecutivo es una erosión del Poder
adquisitivo del poder de compra de los
argentinos por quinto año consecutivo
Que obviamente se sufre en el día a día
la pobreza es mucho más alta como es
como como expectativas y adelante de la
inflación que ella acelere y obviamente
de un desempleo que incluye la cifra
oficial todos aquellos planes sociales
que Obviamente que sin ellos estaría muy
por encima del 11% actualmente
ligeramente por debajo del 7
y la semana pasada hemos visto como
Argentina y el fmi revisaron al alza la
inflación para el 2022 algo que usted
también ha comentado en que puede
afectar esto al acuerdo del pago de la
deuda externa
absolutamente nada el pago de la deuda
externa primero
está dividida en dos grandes grupos uno
es la deuda privada con los bonos que se
ha reestructurado en septiembre del 2020
pero que tiene una escala bastante
benigna para los primeros años en
materia de cupones porque es un Step Up
un escalón que va ascendiendo y que
recién en el 2025 va a tener serias
dificultades Argentina para hacer frente
a esos compromisos con casi 10.000
millones de dólares entre capital e
intereses y la segunda parte son los
préstamos multilaterales en especial del
fmi que van a empezar a hacerse pesados
a partir del año 2026